[Music]
Brad Pitt stepping out and looking sexy
after breaking his silence it was good
it was really good the actor just might
look better than ever at fifty three in
a simple white tee and jeans sunglasses
and boots complete the look as he leaves
his art studio last week Brad broke his
silence about his split from Angelina
Jolie opening up - GQ style saying he
spent a lot of time sculpting to help
himself heal that's life isn't it yeah
challenges and you got some appeals to
face Brad also posed for pics for the
magazine in the photos a tattoo of a
motorcycle is seen on his arm and you
can spot a hint of it here it seems to
be newer ink Pitt is a motorcycle
enthusiast he also spoke out about his
issues with drinking et has learned that
Brad sought counseling to help himself
get sober and that he's been attending
discreet meetings in Los Angeles our
source says quote Pitt has worked very
hard to get his kids back and the whole
family is in a much better place feeling
better and looking great
you